I guess it's our turn huh finally I know
um it's called overcooked overcooked too
oh that's the game oh is that the game
yeah you told me that you'd love that
game by the way I do and I think that's
what inspired me to open up a joombie
and do it in real life right yeah yeah
wait is it over time it's overcooked
it's no it's this gate no the no the
show no relieves overcooked can't say it
over JK overcooked let's go it's the Joe
and Steve episode hell yeah bro hey it's
great to see you I know always great to
see you yeah it's always a treat yeah we
live in Las Vegas but I never seen him
because he's always in Hawaii
like I feel like I got jipped I feel
like I like every time I'm there because
I'm there like every other month right
yeah I'm literally there to just do yard
work clean the house up
reset and then I'm out like a couple
days after but at least you have people
staying at your house yeah yeah yeah
yeah because that's the thing too
because you know like but they don't do
any yard work
so many people are moving to Vegas yeah
it just works out so well yeah yeah well
now's the time where you shouldn't move
to Vegas this is like we're we're here
June 1st don't move to Vegas it's hot
you're gonna hate yourself for moving
there but I'm telling you the rest of
the year it really is the [__] place
yeah I think so I just wish that I could
clone myself so I could enjoy the winter
fall spring Vegas not the summer though
no not the summer although the strip is
kind of cool during the summer it is
because it's so cracking if you like
that energy like the people watching is
hilarious oh dude it's the best no it is
the best place for people watching on
the Earth
I mean if I had the time I think I would
just sit down there and just watch
people and probably document like you
know you ever see somebody like like a
person where you're like where the [__]
does that person go yeah I would love to
just take a camera and actually follow
that person for like a whole day and
just see what the hell they do it's like
real life 90 Day Fiance exactly exactly
because I see a guy with like a shopping
cart and it's it's a it's not it's not
just a shopping cart where you think the
way that you're thinking because you're
a judgy person
he's got a business and he's got like a
bunch of like stuffed butterflies in
there or whatever like they look like
they go in the claw machines and he's
like walking around like basically
dressed like an elf and I'm like where
does this guy go at night and like what
is his name and like who is you know who
is he selling this stuff yeah he's
selling the stuff out of a shopping cart
I saw this when I was at the I was like
hanging out by the Tropicana I want to
know how many he's actually selling
that's what I'm saying right like does
he clear out at the end of the day is he
like look if he does he go to Shark Tank
and he's like Mark I need I have so many
orders I can't fill them
but it must it must work yeah like for
them to do it out there right yeah
because some of these Street Hawkers
like they've been there since I was a
child like the guys with the Flyers
giving out like yeah the clicker guys
yeah yeah they've been there since I was
a kid for sure so I'm like some of these
things are like proven and tested 100
and by the way this is kind of like a
you know I haven't seen this guy in a
while so this is how we catch up with
each other but you know you guys are
here to listen to like why you know how
we how we met I think is the first thing
that that's what the format is per Rye
anime I hear you bro we're back on topic
you know what's unfair yeah is they got
to free they they got to free roll I
know but then for us we had to have a
format well you're the boss you do
whatever you want I know right
much you've always been like that I
always I always hated that about you you
know why is because I basically hire
people so that I don't have to run
anything yeah I've noticed that a little
bit but you you actually know what's you
know what's the best thing about you and
the worst thing about bart is what is
that you are a you're a person who wants
to hire people so that they can do like
their work right and Bart wants to
micromanage them out of existence and
into quitting
and I say that as a brother I love Bart
it's so funny but this is a fact that's
why he's laughing that is a fact Bart
just wants to hire a puppet that he can
move the strings on
Bart wants to extendo cloth
that's his employees it's just the
extendo claw to be a clone of who he is
that's it he's like oh if only I like
technology can clone me yeah that's it
because if barbell could be like 50
Barts oh my God it would be perfect to
be misery for well for everyone who
wasn't a Bart right
no but that that is I think that is a
good quality of leadership when you can
like stand aside yeah and let people do
what you trusted them to do while you
hired them right Bart's really good
because he's so particular and he knows
exactly what he wants
yeah so he's a genius I think this is
why we were able to balance out so well
because I could give a [__] about so
many things oh yeah that like
I need someone like Bart who does care
so much about so many things right he
cares about things that he he's like the
guy who don't cut the pillow tag off
don't cut the tag off the mattress
right he because he read about it you
can't do it it's illegal in life four
states yeah and I think we're in one of
them like it's like that but no I know
exactly what you mean yeah it is
fascinating to see how you guys operate
but it is you guys created a great
symbiosis of like how you guys both
operate businesses couldn't have done it
I mean how long have you guys been in
business together it's insane nobody
likes Islam I think this is our 16th
year it's insane bro yeah it's insane
it's it's been pretty wild it's kind of
weird because
um
I've never approached this like a
business yeah like
the way that I work jumbi the way that
I've built other Concepts or whatever
it's been com I have a different hat on
and it's probably because I don't have
BART to lean on so then I know what's
not there so then I have to take on the
role of like you know some of the areas
that I probably wouldn't want to take on
yeah
you're one of the most unique people
I've ever met and I and I actually mean
that like like in the best way like I
really don't think I have a bad thing to
say about you oh thanks bro no likewise
I I really mean it like I think you're
one of the best dudes I've ever met like
I actually like in a weird way look up
to you even because you're just such a
kind person like I like like I've said
before and then like it happened
um in real life I don't know how much I
can say it but but like I I was just
saying at one time like we're doing a JK
episode we were kind of going deep on
something and I was like dude Joe owes
the Jake it was the one about you for 20
minutes it was like oh when I wasn't
here setting up like what do we ask Joe
for 20 minutes right and then I was like
and it was like Hey like Joe
um I was like Joe would take the shirt
off his [__] back if you're like I
like your shirt and and like we had a
friend who had their car stolen and Joe
just gives her his car
like that that's the most Joe thing ever
he like literally did it it's like not
something I'm saying that he wanted to
do and she said no he actually did yeah
and like that's you know it was like it
was like how I am with crypto I find a
gem and then I'm like see it's working
out when I saw you do that I was like
see I'm [__] bank shot in this [__]
yeah I think we're very similar in the
in the way where it's like we it's like
it's not fun to be the only one winning
right and also if you have a friend that
probably it's and it's easy for you to
help them out like for you it's so easy
to just tell us all the information that
you learned right it doesn't take that
much Sacrifice from you to do that but
it would mean the world to someone who
doesn't have the time to study crypto or
whatever and I had a hell of a ride with
you doing that right right of Lifetime
and I and I feel like which one
oh so many but I feel like that's
basically
the same way that I think but I
expressed it differently or like I give
differently
um and and I I also I also believe that
like you gotta protect your group yes
like so if people are in trouble like
you don't send thoughts and prayers to
your group right you have to actually do
something and so
um I mean that's just how you should
operate you know it's just it's just the
way the world should work or else it's
like why be a friend or why dude loyalty
is everything yeah like 100 and that you
know a lot of people say that but like
it really is it really is so important
to show it right like I think you do
that like basically all day long yeah
um but nope again Joe's not the person
who will bring it up so I'm gonna do it
thanks man no bro I really really always
have appreciated you I think that you
know JK is such a special place I always
try to say that as as long as I've been
here and I've been here for a while I
guess okay I think yeah almost eight
years really has it been damned it feels
so fast insane yeah I feel like like
it's like birds of a feather right like
when we first met oh we're gonna go hit
that topic right
um
it was I was at uh Tim's roast yes and
then Nikki's already been a guest
because I think Taryn uh uh Taryn
Southern Southern yeah yeah yeah she
introduced us because she was like oh
Nikki's so funny yeah you know and she
did great she's such a nice ass probably
she said that too yeah she's like she's
she was she naturally just fit in Nikki
was great she worked out really well
with us and we had her for a while and
she would mention you from time to time
she goes yeah yeah my
um I don't know if you were her
boyfriend or her husband yeah yeah and
then she would say like oh he has a
YouTube channel too and then um it was
like in passing so we never really paid
any attention to that
but then when we saw you at the roast
and then she introduced us and you are
hilarious like you had us dying in tears
bro like it was so good
and then I also um it clicked that I
seen your content before the Bangbus
stuff yes sir I thought that was so
freaking hilarious
you would tell all these guys like yeah
you want to [__] porn stars and then the
girls would be sitting next to them and
they're like oh my God and then they
would switch positions and these guys
would come in and that was like one of
my
funniest I I would like die like you
know what laughing you know what Bonnie
Rotten told me she's a porn star yeah
she was like what's great about this is
that they always do think that they're
gonna get to [__] us like like even just
socially right like they just meet us
and like out and about and they like put
their hand on her ass in a photo and all
that stuff and she was like I really
like how like this is like basically
like a [__] you to that and I was like
oh you get it like that's really cool so
it's like you flip it on them yeah and
and I and I yeah so I remember like
I didn't subscribe to your channel but
your videos would pop up like they're so
viral I was just so far yeah and then so
like throughout the years I would see it
and then I made the connection and I was
like oh [__] you're that guy right yeah
and I was like why didn't we ever invite
you and then the first day you came by I
think it was like immediately we clicked
100 dude and it was never a good
experience before yeah honestly and I've
been I did YouTube with like dogs with
cassim and this group called the station
and she had Carl and all these people
and yeah I had hyper-clicked with them
as well but then with you guys it was
like doing cocaine and then clicking it
was like we've known each other it was
that kind of clicking comfortable so
like we have some more values we see the
world the same way we have more of a
cynical take but we prefer joy and we
all got into entertainment to actually
craft something yes rather than to be
famous or anything like that never had
an interest in Fame really just wanted
to say something and I think that's what
kind of separated us from a lot of other
YouTubers because most YouTubers are
literally there for attention Fame and
because they're lonely they don't even
know what they want to say exactly it's
the weirdest thing yeah but they find a
way to grab attention and then I mean
that's their thing right but for us I
wanted to create something and then you
had that writing background you had
Talent you you wrote movies and then so
I think like I think my average IMDb
score is like 5.8 what does that mean
it's really good what's what's that out
of ten yeah
it's really good that's above average to
a kid who went to school and like barely
got through that's pretty [__] great
but I think that's where our deep
respect came from is like you were an
actual like Master at your craft that we
loved which is comedy and at the time it
was like dope because it was almost like
we got to draft you know LeBron on our
team oh but dude I I don't agree with
that but I really appreciate that but no
I I mean honestly you guys I I like I
said I look up to you personally
um and I look up to what you guys built
here like more than anything as well
like it's I've always said this about
the room I say like I wish that more
people knew how important it is like
what you guys built here and like how
people can still say whatever they want
and maybe it's because you guys just
figured out how to like find a certain
group of people who are just gonna ride
with you no matter the [__] what our
fans are like third eye hardcore yeah I
sat next to one on the plane today yeah
my name's Aaliyah yeah and she was like
you better shout me out and I was like
I'll shout you out but she was like I
[__] love you guys love JK and the
but the best thing is that you like
she's like 23 years old yeah like how
the [__] did we we get Alia she was like
what 11 when she started watching dude
yeah like we raised a lot of people is
what I'm realizing yeah you know there's
people that are like you put me through
college
adulthood whatever now I'm a 50 year old
man yeah so legit that's good when the
time it does it does feel like that dude
it does it does but no but but so like
you know it's but it's it's captivating
to see like what you guys created and
then for some reason Maybe YouTube just
hates you guys enough or they don't pay
attention yeah they don't pay attention
they don't know what we're saying here
right and they're and like because I've
seen people get their channels taken
down for Less right than what we [__]
do on the weekly I know and it's
probably one of the beauties of like
being so niche but not too freaking
popular right so then like if we were
too too big then like mainstream big
then it's dangerous yeah or like if you
have too many uh sponsors that are like
that own you basically yes because the
the when the bigger your company is the
more you have on the line the more you
know people you need to like make sure
their jobs are safe like there's just
more things that make you go
um I guess mainstream and safe yeah and
I [__] hated that you know it's one
of the it's one of the worst things
about Commerce and just like advertising
because we all need it yeah right
obviously the ads are great like we do
it off the Record and it's brought to
you by right so we need it it's great it
helps but then it does suck to have a
corporate Overlord but thankfully for
some reason like I said I know it's not
like two gods are blessing it's like you
got hymns who are like hey you better
[__] be chill about this topic
you know when we're laughing about like
yeah or like when we're laughing about
like some guy who got mangled in a
[__] car accident and hins is like
hey you better be careful that guy has a
Rossini hairline I know right well we're
trying to like sell lawn care service
and then like right after the ad read
Bart Is straddling Anthony and like
humping them from the back you know he's
mock [__] his face
oh
and that by the way actually happened on
our show many many times so but we've
had so many years of just like memories
and laughs here dude this room the
amount of last is bounced off these
walls is insane it's pretty the energies
I think there's definitely some residual
laughter here from all those years what
do you think changed like because I
gotta I've been here for a long time
yeah I for a while I think that you were
kind of you know maybe checked out as
the word yeah you were focusing on
yourself which I think is really
important and I don't denigrate you for
that I think it's really really a
crucial thing but what brought you back
like made you feel like you're kind of
you know alive again here
yeah man I think um when you do
something routinely for too many years
and then at one point I felt like I was
losing control of JK like Bart 2 right
well Bart was more so he was really
spread thin yeah like he just had taika
and then he was moving and then just you
know Bart was like I'm only here to film
and then I can't really do anything else
Nick Nick was always yeah Nick with his
clients right yeah and then for me I
think um
I can't pinpoint what exactly it was but
I don't think anything in my life felt
like was working out correctly
so there was a time when I felt like
everything I set my mind to I was
achieving and I actually had a goal but
then for the first time it felt like I
was aimlessly like going through motions
and routines but like nothing was
working out and there were nothing but
problems that I couldn't fix it was like
a sinking ship that I kept throwing
water out but I couldn't stop right and
there was a lot of
um that going on so I think that took a
toll on me personally just from
observing too there's a lot of strange
like internal angst right like a weird
feeling of like well they used to do it
this way and now they don't yeah and
like [__] them and I'm like
do you guys realize what you get to do
for a living right here yeah like do you
realize that it was very odd and I'm not
really throwing anybody under the bus I
just don't think that they they knew
like how this stuff works yet yeah I
think
there was a
you know like over the years I think
like I was learning how to be a boss and
so like communicating to the team
certain things some people had different
desires and wishes and maybe
for them too they didn't have the
courage to just go out and pursue their
own thing and maybe they felt like as a
friend they had to stick around
um because that's how we've been doing
it for so long and we never had that
discussion right so I think like
after I started to deal with it
individually like let's say former
employees or whatever right
um as those things were being dealt with
I started to feel better and more
relieved because the Clutter was being
cleaned up you know which is a [__] up
thing when it comes to people
not just people no you're I know what
you're saying no the Clutter of the Mind
exactly the mindset
yeah yeah yeah I'm having Joe's back
yeah yeah because because no the mindset
was so weird around here for like a
little while and it was very like it was
just like
I just remember being confused like I'm
always I try to be empathetic I really
try to understand where people are
coming from I really do but then
sometimes I'm like dude at the end of
the day though this is crazy I didn't
get to do this dude and I give
a whole month off but I pay them for a
full 12. bro and then we do paid company
vacations all in all the time and if you
want to bring your significant other we
pay for them too how many times we go
out to eat and like Bart and Joe pick up
the tab exactly and then so for me like
the every time links and things that I
was hearing sometimes I'm just like
where's this coming from but also it
wasn't just
um internal like
things that were bothering me about the
company
um it was also the fan base
so there is like you said the Die Hard
group that absolutely love us right yeah
we raised them since they were 10 and a
half years old yeah we were saying bad
words and being racist
exactly and they're like thank you I'm
47 now and I'm a doctor
you inspired me yeah dressing like a
mother and talking [__]
yeah thank you for denigrating the human
race by like a half a percentage point
yeah um I think it was also yeah like we
were pandering at one point because I
remember we did I remember I got so dude
I want everybody to feel like welcomed
me too bro right so I thought it would
be good on the panel to have different
voices obviously and I'm not saying
that's wrong but the different voices
have to be intelligent and be able to
debate it and be able to make sense
right it's it's not just someone who's
being disagreeable but they're also
butchering their position and then also
at the end of the day it has to be
comedy so then if there's no comedy
someone there just wants to kind of
refute your points or maybe shut it down
completely there's no debate there's no
discussion and it ends up becoming like
this like train wreck of a talk and then
I'm just like but hey there's a lot of
nodding I know there's one person
talking in a lot of nodding in the room
a lot of people going oh okay well and
then looking at the clock like Anthony
Lee style you know how Anthony does that
[__] and he looks at the clock he's
trying to run away yeah yeah yeah but no
they're like looking at the clock like
all right yeah I'm just gonna nod for
the next like [__] six minutes and I
remember everyone was paranoid even in
the whole comedy space about cancel
culture during lockdown so then we
started becoming super careful boys you
know because we were just like oh [__]
we can't be the person that we were
before and then it was weird too because
the fans that loved us for the same
jokes that we pulled just a year ago
they started to Virtue signal and they
would just be like Oh I'm mature now I
don't like these jokes anymore and I'm
like oh [__] you then what did you like
last week I know it was fine when you're
laughing at Us and other cultures but
then when it became about you or
something you know now you're yeah
you're fragile about it what are you
talking about I know dude like would you
like 10 days ago
like compared to not no but that didn't
happen to a lot of people and honestly
we kind of were trying to I think we
overread the room probably probably
right and we overreacted probably but
bro the circumstances of the time were
so weird that like I don't it's hard to
just say well I blame us for that it's
just it's one of those things all
comedians dude like
big big names powerful everybody
everybody even like YouTubers like Jenna
Marbles quit because she's not back yet
I know and I was like the hate was so
strong she was at my wedding I love
Jenna Marbles yeah she's awesome and I'm
like
the hay was so strong that basically she
was just like I want any I don't have to
even do this anymore [__] this but
that's where I didn't want to I I knew
that
there's no point in making the the Mad
crowd happy like I still have at least
50 percent of people out there who love
us yes and why are we not talking to
them why are we attending to the other
people who are like frustrated at us
what do you think that comes from for
you personally like like is there a need
to respond to the criticism like to
defend yourself is that why you want to
lash out and do that
what do you mean the uh oh when when you
know I think all of us have had moments
where we overreact to criticism yeah
where do you think it comes from for you
oh I don't like how it was damaging the
group because like so for example the
girls of the group were very affected by
the negative comments and stuff like
that right extremely so and for me I was
really frustrated because I wanted to
just focus on the fans that love us
because there's always going to be hate
and at the same time sometimes
um them just talking about us is a is
good marketing but then so good some of
the members that were in our group
didn't even want to become social media
Stars so they're not gonna
you know
take it as like the same way as someone
who's prepared to be an Entertainer can
take it like you might like I saw that
as opportunity as like oh controversy
and it's fun because I don't know these
people and you know they have an opinion
fine but it keeps us kind of relevant
and then we can play with that and then
I think it's really to me there's
there's no personal attachment to it
basically but like
what I didn't like to see were my
friends being so depressed and upset
from the actions of these horrible
people saying these [__] up things
right so then I tone down my behavior
because I didn't want to attract
attention
negative attention or even put them in
the position that can get residual
cancel because I did something right you
know like that was happened in the Geo
where Bart would do something and then
they would start bombing Geo's DM saying
how dare you allow your husband to do
this and that and then she was just
getting stressed out right yeah so I was
like this is why I believe like having
careful with boys I feel so much more
like chill because like we don't have to
worry about that layer of like everybody
in that room has has each other's back
right everybody yeah and it wasn't
always like that here and that was kind
of the problem because I also felt like
hey I have your back but then they were
so worried about the commenters that
they turned on us because they didn't
want they wanted to separate themselves
from us right like oh I'm not like that
you know I'm not racist like them or
whatever the [__] I'm like what they
would say that [__] in the room I know
bro I was like wait what the [__] yeah
wait what the [__]
I like last week again 10 days ago
didn't hear you talk like that now yeah
yeah and so like now you're joining this
mob that
because you're so afraid of them saying
hurtful things to you not that you
actually believe it because when the
cameras are off you make the jokes we
know what you said right and then so
those are the kind of things that were
really like pissing me off because I was
seeing the true colors of certain
members
um and I was like I'm gonna name them
name them all
but I was like I'm doing all this work
to protect and I'm doing all this stuff
to hold myself back so we don't you know
whatever but then like
at you know but I don't know it was just
it was just a weird time right I don't
know what your perspective was during
that same as you it was very frustrating
it was very weird and it wasn't like
it's not like I have the tablet with the
truth and I'm trying to show it to
everybody it was very like murky right
everyone's just trying to figure out
what the [__] going on anyway I think
now we're able to talk about it in
retrospect exactly because we dissected
it but in the moment I didn't know
that's what was happening like I didn't
know they were the culprit or or the
audience was the culprit I I was just in
there like you know what something about
this isn't enjoyable anymore exactly and
I always you know I always like I said I
try to root for people's takes and their
opinions and it doesn't matter if I
agree with them or not I just want to
understand where they're coming from and
I think that's what helps me be like
emotionally
um intelligent when when I'm talking to
people yeah but with this it was very
much like okay I have your back I can I
can see myself having your back but then
I like having an out-of-body experience
I'm like you don't have r though yeah
we're not saying the right things you
don't have our back no and that's when
I'm like these four these I guess 17
walls however the room is shaped so
weird
um you know they're not we're not
shielded here now yeah it is different
now yeah it's much different than when I
came in and we hit it off and like we
had that [__] like oh don't worry
we're in a comedy Rider's room and we
can say whatever the [__] we want now
all of a sudden it's like no there's
there's peephos in here and like people
are being self-aware and they want to
make sure that everyone who's watching
sees that they're being self-aware and
good and doing the right thing and
that's what pissed me off yep and I'll
give you guys a little hint too because
um there were moments where certain
people panel uh also had control of the
back end
um whether it was the topic or editing
style or whatever and it wasn't just one
person it was it was it was a couple yes
and it was also during a time uh during
covid right yes there's six seats here
it was really hard to fill those seats
um there's been even episodes where I
sat next to a mannequin to cover so we
can keep the ones where I got I had to
go to the hospital yeah and then you
were you were saying you you gotta I had
a I had a weird like heart palpitation
thing yeah yeah runs my family
apparently but yeah
that was crazy we thought you were like
gonna Croak on us well Timmy D thought I
was about to die covet but I was like I
don't this is not covered symptoms guys
my heart is just going insane yeah but
yeah but yeah it was it was things like
that where it was like later when the
video goes up
we're like that
wait a minute that was edited to make
that person look so good and I was like
by the editor perhaps yeah and I was
like how the [__] did this happen yeah
and it was one of those things where
like I remember I kind of just
contextualize this yeah yeah I remember
being like Joe do you see what they just
did to you in this video yeah and you
were like No And I was like dude you
need to watch it dude I'm like this
person gets to [__] take shots at you
and you're you're doing your thing
reading the room doing what you do right
and then this person can stick shots to
you and edit it so that they're even
more accentuated right so they look more
they look correct way more correct
because for me like we're playing a game
here right the the ultimate yeah we do
get serious and we do talk about
politics and all these things but the
ultimate goal is fun yeah it's fun let's
let's construct a joke together or like
let's have a good conversation
but the way that this was edited was
like really a slam dunk and then when
you read all the comments it would just
it would just be like oh wow look look
he put him in his place and I'm all like
okay so it's a competition yeah so I'm
like that sucks because you know I'm
over here if he's if he's Bank shotting
all these things right you don't need to
zoom in on Jordan Duncan you just need
to show the court exactly but the
emphasis the emphasis is that's why
you're you're putting the thumb on the
scale and that was just a cop out right
it's a cop-out and it's insecurity yeah
and then it's okay and then I that's
what I say I really do try to understand
people it's obviously there's some kind
of weird insecurity going on and so this
person's trying to emphasize their
points and they're using editing
techniques to do it and it's like this
just like you're not having JK's back
though right and that's what doesn't sit
well with me because as an improviser
and like dude that is one of the lamest
things you could ever say don't worry I
know I know that that is but one of the
core things is trust yeah and in any
relationship it's trust and so when
we're all gonna take shots and step out
on the limbs and sometimes we go for
that big joke and it doesn't land and we
[__] spin around on home plate
instead of hitting the ball
um shouldn't we try to have each other's
backs no because we're on a team we're
in New Jersey 100 but I realized that so
the difference here is we're improv
troop this guy thought he was a part of
the debate team yeah so the difference
is like some so so that's that's when
things went South is that something
that's not just one person no like as an
example I'm talking about when things
didn't go well when I felt like I was
losing control of the company in general
like things like that like I'm the owner
of the company right and then they're
going to construct a video that
basically sacrifices completely my
Integrity my Kalima on you right yeah
it's like okay I mean you whatever if
that's what makes you feel good you know
I don't to me it's not a big deal that's
why I didn't you know react to it in
that way but I just thought okay a
person that's willing to do that
means one they don't respect me correct
right and then so that was more
disappointing than anything because it
was like you know I let people talk [__]
all the time because it's funny you know
what I mean and you're really good at
that and I read the comments all they're
like how how can Joe let them do this so
oblivious I know and I'm like Ugh yeah
they don't know if the joke is good and
if it's true why not right I don't know
but I also think that shows more
strength when you don't get your panties
in a bunch exactly dude God damn if the
people who don't take things too
seriously yeah are always my favorite
people and why should you from people
that you feel safe with exactly like
that doesn't make any sense and that's
the Integrity of the writer's room of
Jake and that's what I always loved
about this room and that's what I would
say the the room has to be protected no
matter what it has to be and and it
wasn't and that's where I think things
started to really make me feel horrible
because I was like whoa I thought you
know
we were all on the same page exactly
doing the same thing common goal but
some some people had personal agendas
they wanted to be the star
they wanted their
whatever five seconds of fame or
whatever and I realized that some
members would
um use this as an opportunity to build
because what one thing that I wanted to
do was
um you know as we all grow together I
wanted to put everybody in front of the
camera right so like certain members
were able to build their own following
because I thought that that would be a
great way where hey if you build your
own following whether it's in editing
writing whatever you do you're going to
inspire so many people
and honestly bro I think it's one of the
biggest things I've learned from you
personally is that I always took I think
maybe too seriously like the idea of
like well like this person's trained I
remember saying that to Nikki a million
and a half times they're trained they're
comedically trained blah blah blah train
train train yeah and you will take
people who aren't quote unquote trained
and but you put them in this great
environment that you've built and you
know how to extract like the best from
them because it you know it takes time
and I've seen people flourish from that
like who wouldn't traditionally even
have that shot and I just think that
that's [__] why you're so good at
what you do yeah I think uh I know how
to pick
like a strength yeah and then see like
oh I can I can see where this is gonna
go in a year or two and then so I've
seen that yeah and I'll give them a shot
because also some of them like who would
give Nick as many shots as you gave him
who who in the world and we all love and
yeah right and we love him yeah and
you're and there was something there
like even as he was deflector Nick and
all that stuff for a long time but he is
we love Nick like it's so funny how much
we love Nick but like it is and like the
careful boys right as it exists today
which is a totally different thing it's
a fun group bro and when we have the
core character no one's a comedian no
and that's my favorite thing not even
bro I'm more than mine I'm a tuber
comedian but what I'm saying is like the
the core group of the careful boys is my
favorite group yeah and I I can't wait
even like when I see my phone light up
and it's from careful boy shot I can't
wait to see what you guys have to say
about the world yeah and I think that
that's what people have have really
hooked on to but like that doesn't
happen anywhere like that I think that
is a result of like you guys incubating
this like crazy experiment and then like
it evolving past you know maybe we even
you know came out of the woke era as
careful boys obviously it's the title
but capitalizing on it in such a
different way I think by just taking
normal people like [__] dancers
there's more dancers than regular people
on the show yeah and dancers are not
even you know look I don't like dancers
I'll be honest I don't like them yeah
cans right there I don't I don't like
can't because he's a dancer no but it's
the it really is um who would give a
dancer a platform to talk
but is it not something that we're all
thankful for like honestly yeah like
Anthony Lee
he brings in so much he's so everyone
has different qualities about them that
are so strong that I'm like dude they're
just not either harnessing it or
someone's not seeing this and Norma me
would go like hey can we have that
dancer like
maybe you could do a podcast with like a
dancer's like
for I don't know because it actually
doesn't make sense like if you think
about what I should be doing is I should
be going to all these improvs with an
ice house and I should be trying to
scout those guys to be a part of the
group I should be
um you know hiring an editing team from
maybe an editing company or whatever uh
that's where it should come from right
I never did anything that way and I
think
it's probably because we had to be
resourceful from the get because we
never had funding we had to do it all
from but why did you guys get because
like you guys at one point
I'm not gonna talk numbers but you guys
were pulling in like insane amounts of
money a month right yep and you had the
option to do the [__] thing on which
tubers fall fall victim to right I'm
gonna hire official Hollywood help right
we tried and then we interviewed them
and it just I think it just didn't work
out with the company culture because
like there were guys that wanted to come
in and and then we were just like you
know what there's something off here it
just doesn't work
and at the time my vision for it and it
worked out for almost over a decade the
the whole family company environment
what you saw on the Vlogs all that stuff
was genuinely real you know
and I'm just talking about the dark side
here because there's no company with no
dark side but if you think about how
Disney
right they're perfect no dark side yeah
but if you think about
in general I feel like compared to my
other friends businesses and all that I
feel like so lucky that we were able to
go for such a long stint without the
issues even the issue that I just
brought up right now with like maybe
this guy you know or or or gal or or
Anonymous person
you know maybe they edited something for
their own ego or whatever not for the
benefit of the the group it was still
harmless compared to what like the
nightmares that my friends have were you
still I mean you know I think the way
that you framed it was really good
because you you almost viewed as a
personal failing yeah that like you you
were there sleepwalking while that
happened almost in a way and like I you
know I think that that happens to
everybody they just there's a flaw in
the system there's a monkey in the
wrench and you don't you're like okay I
acknowledge that now
yeah and I I think I didn't foresee
certain things about human nature
because I just couldn't believe that
some people will be that
um
like they want validation so badly or
they were so desperate to I'm like be
right about something or or want the
affection of strangers because my mind
doesn't operate in the same light where
um you know if the negative comments
don't affect me that much
I just assume that people in my group
wouldn't be that effective yes but then
they are like they it took out Julia
like it destroyed her for years but dude
I like I said that before on a JK video
and people are like he's lying that's
not why she left them like no she
literally said that that's why she left
like yeah she's talking about she said
it in I know the video but they don't
want to accept it it's because you guys
are toxic all of us we're just two tops
yeah but I think um the people that were
toxic they don't remember right there's
you know people have amnesia and I think
that's the issue is like they don't
understand how much their actions and
what they say
can really harm someone on the other end
yes like
if it's like me or Bart it doesn't
matter you know but like someone like
Julia or someone who genuinely loves
everybody and wants to be accepted by
everybody
that weren't meant to be
entertainers in the first place Julia
was here to be behind the scenes but as
a supporter she did everything that we
basically needed help for and if it
meant being in front of the camera she
joined in and then so she doesn't like
attention she doesn't want to be a
famous person but when you say Julia was
loving
is that really true because she didn't
love Josh as much as I wanted her to
as a fan
you talk about the fanfics yeah yeah oh
my God
we got some dirty dirty dirty dirty fans
hilarious fans out there dude one of my
favorite by the way one of my favorite
moments in JK Discord history which
there's there's a JK Discord hey check
it out yeah on patreon.com jk just
kidding news yeah you got to join the
just kidding news to be a part of our
special Discord it's great Discord we
had an older Discord when we were just
getting going right but I remember one
of my favorite moments was I started a
channel called Josh and Julia
forever yeah yeah and it was I was just
trying to enable the whoever amount of
people there were that were trying to
get Josh and Julie together and I was
like this is so funny to me I can't
handle it so I'm not gonna like use
whatever I have to bring it up in into
the surface and then I remember doing a
I remember it was like Halloween time
and I remember writing like age I was
like it's it's sweaty on the set of just
kidding
I'm like Julie is like oh my God is the
air conditioner broken and Josh walks in
the room he's like I just checked yeah
it's definitely down for the camp
and I remember Sean who is a JK Legend
we love Sean Sean was so scared and
nervous about what I was gonna write
next that he started deleting everything
that I was saying
deleting everything that I was saying
because he was like this is so risque
but the fact that to him it was so
risque it was just so it's so funny it's
so funny
yes exactly he was like I can't believe
he's like is Steve gonna have it's like
Josh Julia do simulated [__] on this
bike he's like I can't I can't even get
to the [__] party
dude I was on it well my bit was just
gonna be about like all the equipment
that JK is not working but like like
with sexual undertones but then he
couldn't handle it any of that if you
thought you were gonna go straight into
the [__] [__] shot wow just like
talking about the infrastructure Jake is
not great yeah yeah uh it was no I do
remember that oh so fun so fun a gem a
gem of a person I love Sean but that's
what I'm saying like with this unique
group right like Julia does love
everybody yeah like like Julia I get how
fans go like oh Julia would work with
this person this person even though
she's like had a boyfriend for like
[__] years now
um but she is a special person and the
idea that but the idea right the the
little like um dark corner of that is
that people think that like somehow JK
chased her away and it's like oh she
yeah she literally thrived from JK
that's why she says happy birthday to me
till this day every [__] Year all the
time now but people can't accept it they
need the dramos yeah right but this is
what I mean by like there's always going
to be these crazy folks with with wild
imaginations agendas right but it's like
we should never forget the actual fans
that love us the silent ones the ones
that watch they don't con they don't
comment they don't participate in an
account no they and they come out of the
Woodworks too like when there are videos
like on JK where we talk about it they
do come out you know and then you'll
just see all of a sudden a thousand
comments on one video saying like we're
still here and so blah blah I love it
too and then the best part is seeing
them face to face yeah honestly I was
having a bad day this morning because
like the airport stuff blah blah and
then I sat like I said I sat next to JK
fan and I was like man I'm so I'm so
lucky right like I can't believe how
lucky we all are because you and Bart
had a stupid idea in a parking lot like
[__] 15 years ago and and Hannah says
this too like she's like I can always
tell when when they're your fan and I'm
like why it goes
um because they dress cool and then they
they're they're actually cool people
yeah so I'm like it's rare that we're
lucky right that we have fans that are
just normal human beings legit yeah yeah
some of the other fans I'm just like man
like you got some weird in cells are
like you got some wow they're like
horrible looking people
did I'll send you a link to it you'll
like this guy oh yeah but he does toy
train stuff on YouTube and can you
imagine his fan base like [__] [__] dude
like somebody's he probably has like
six-year-olds and 50 year olds that look
like six exactly dude and you know you
know that he's like at the airport yeah
or he's like you know somewhere social
and he's like to his wife he's like yeah
this guy's like hey can you put a dildo
in the front of the [__] train and
I'm like God damn it dude he's like yeah
I just want to get on all fours in front
of that [__] train on them train
tracks all tied up oh my god dude really
you're my fan and then like he gets some
six-year-old kid too who's like hey I
really like trades oh my god he has to
have a whole conversation with them
but he's like here's my fan okay cool
always on my patreon all right yeah I
gotta be cool
you imagine the nightmare I know but we
have the coolest the best fans I think
um so like slowly gaining back control
of this having a team that's fun yeah
attitude is so different everyone wants
to be here they want to be here there's
no complaining there's no like who
[__] about being a JK no nobody if I
if I have one complaint it's lighting
here because like it's just pretty bad
it reminds me of corporate office but
like I say it out in the open like I
know that's what I you know to me if you
have [__] to say just say it that's the
that's the biggest thing is like I don't
think we're unapproachable never think
we're people that you can't talk to so I
don't know why like you're just you'll
take minimal action that's what people
don't know that's why I don't know why
it's like why did they pent it up I
don't know I don't know I don't know
because you guys make fun of you guys
more than anybody makes one of you guys
but that's why you know like like I've
said many times My love language is
getting my balls busted and so that's
why we all got on so quickly so I think
that's that was probably one of my like
early leadership flaws is not accurately
understanding the relationship I have
with my team or like
also
um probably not being approachable
because I've heard that like you know
I'm intimidating or like I'm I'm
whatever or or difficult to talk to or
maybe I did do something early on
because like we had members that were
with us for over 10 years right so I'm
like maybe they're holding on to
something of
20 25 year old Joe right you know and
then 25 year old Joe might have reacted
differently when they tried to uh bring
up a concern or whatever and then maybe
they didn't you know forgive me for
whatever reason 10 years later they they
might still think I'll react the same
way I don't know but I think there's
definitely some baggage there that I'll
take responsibility for but the but the
thing is I never got the opportunity to
have that like sit down and like let's
hash this out and it just it just some
some stuff was just like
um a big surprise like when I I never
predicted that certain members would not
be able to handle the fame like when I
put him in front of the camera and all
this stuff
um
like they would all of a sudden get a
following and all this stuff and
and I was kind of shocked because
because like let's like let's say it's
an insignificant compared to you know
some of the people that we have as
guests or whatever but they're acting
more Diva than the people that are yeah
so you know like cool JK fans just
relating to the nice person more than
the diva person
and so then they're getting more of a
following yeah right yeah yeah yeah
you're right or like yeah more like
they're they're they might be acting
like a diva even all of a sudden because
they have a following oh well yeah
that's what I mean that's what I'm like
shock me because certain people are like
I never thought that you would be this
way yeah and on top of that you're never
trying to be a star or or Talent you
know on camera person yeah and then
there's a lot of things about people in
general that I learned over the years
that that I didn't predict well
I did it in some ways but in other ways
I didn't yeah is that something where
you're like I know what to do now or is
it just something where you're like [__]
it I'm just gonna believe in people
anyway and we'll see what happens
I think I know how to give my time
to people that
show actual like
I don't want to say promise but like
it's more like
um the older you get right you assess
people better hopefully yeah because in
the beginning I thought that all people
needed was resources so they can pursue
the things that they need or maybe
information
but I think I was completely wrong about
that like you can't teach someone
motivation you can't teach someone
inspiration you can't teach someone like
positive attitude those things are just
like
inherent behavioral traits and unless
they want to
um those things will just not
like you can't make someone stop
complaining like if that's their
personality oh you can hit them or throw
them down the stairs
but if that's if they're like an extreme
cynic right yeah and then they complain
about everything like that's just who
they are and you gotta accept that and
roll with it because let's say like
you're in a creative space and you just
need an environment where people are
brainstorming not someone who's like
shutting everything down
then you just then it's my fault as a
leader to plug in the wrong person in
this group for that kind of environment
instead of molding them where does Bart
come in with that for your process like
you're plugging somebody in is there a
conversation or is it just like I'm
plugging somebody in and Barge just like
I trust you in most cases people were
plugged in out of necessity
and he I don't know like we're both very
like hey we don't know what the answer
is going to be so let's try it unless
there's like us hard no like there's
certain times when I gave extreme like I
had to fight Bart on certain things like
in the beginning there was another
competitive competing
um website not YouTube I don't even
remember the name now because they got
so wrecked by you guys you wrecked them
so bad you don't remember the name yeah
but it was like
it was another website called I don't
know
um but they were they were actually
paying so this was during the time when
YouTube wasn't paying yeah yeah yeah and
Bart was like we should jump onto this
platform because
um they're paying their creators and
then I was like no YouTube is what
everyone's using it's gonna be Google
it's gonna be like the platform so even
if it doesn't pay it's probably gonna be
that's tight dude Bart was so stupid
[Laughter]
I have to search like to the beginning
of our you know business no that's
really good to dig something
you had a gun you had a good Instinct on
it yeah but there are only certain
things like that where I'm like if I
don't have a hard stance I don't fight
him that much yeah yeah
but with people how about with people
with people is there conversations is it
like you know because we have guests in
all the time like is there you guys
check in after or how's that go
no actually it's been I think the
the
organic growth over time like because if
you remember the way that we built was
basically I need this person well I just
need a person to be here you know what I
mean like like even Geo it was like hey
we need a girl for this skit can you
find someone nope or the girl last
minute bail the actor bailed so now Geo
has to play right you know
I think you're one of the
more toward the end where I actually
chose
um so like
after being a guest uh for so many I
guess years before we actually committed
to having you on board like as like a
salary a professional yeah like that
um
I think it's because well one like uh we
like your taste of Comedy but you also
had skills because you know we wanted to
write a bunch of scripts yeah so it came
in the form of like maybe a consultant
or someone that would but then you just
ended up being a part of the writer's
Circle yeah yeah and then from then it
was like just having you on consistently
as like a host or even before that just
consistently on the show
because
um after David stepped away we just
needed you no but it worked out well
yeah it was I mean honestly I mean and
we all love David I I there's no shoes
to fill per se I just I always loved
David uh when David's on it's so [__]
fun too yeah but no it it um yeah for me
it was just great because it came at the
right time for me my channel got
demonetized all that [__] yeah and then
I just remember being like well what's
next in this chapter of my life like I
but you were actually like disgusted and
picked too it wasn't because like well
David's gone we need Steve it was more
like no you were already here I never
got that impression from you guys and
you guys were but you guys are very like
not official when you guys do something
like that like there was no ticker Day
Parade or like a handshake like send her
a handshake with a photo it was very
much just like I I just kept getting
booked every week and I was like I guess
I'm like regular now and I think Nick
went through that recently too and like
Anthony went through that recently too
and we all kind of had a conversation
about about this like when we were
walking like a month and a half ago but
no it's just funny how you you know I do
appreciate that though like it is
um not stressful in a way yeah because
you don't like put that on someone and I
literally like we just date until it's
like you know this but I do respect you
guys and what you guys built so much
that I didn't want to presume like I
didn't want to go like well I'm I'm the
I am a member you know you know I really
like liked you guys and like didn't want
to presume anything yeah but um yeah
when that kind of got confirmed to me I
was very happy obviously the day I like
like I told Nikki the day that I met you
guys like I got in the car and I said I
could do that every week forever yeah
and it doesn't feel like work and I've
never said that about anybody right like
like I I and I'm not kidding and I'm not
dissing anybody in my past I'm just
saying like there are drawbacks to
shooting things sometimes and that's
normal it's very normal right but like
with you guys it was just like I was
hanging out and like you guys say for
your um your why like why you guys did
the show it's like we're hanging out in
the parking lot after we all like had
dinner yeah and like it is like that it
is and and it and it just didn't feel
like we were doing any work at all yeah
and it hasn't frankly for [__] eight
years or whatever that's why we keep it
going we take a 40 pay cup
hey I look forward to every pay cut I
know yeah and it's and it's funny too
because we keep growing in Subs but it's
like now yeah finally right because we
were going down we were at like 1.8 and
then 1.7 and then it goes right back to
1.9 it's gonna go back to 1.8 I'm done
yeah dude I was actually catching up
with you guys with a dead Channel
really yeah that's how I knew I was like
well how many Subs is your non-active
0.7 oh my God I was like dude I was like
I am on a sinking ship but I think for
some reason I'm uh a zeppelin coming up
out of the clouds so as a as a business
owner right we've kind of touched on all
that a lot but as a creative yourself is
there anything in JK or like you know is
there something you have inside you
creatively that you can't get out yet
because you do this so routinely and
then you go back to June B Hawaii
um I think during covid and the whole
cancel culture and all these things
right like that was the first time when
I felt like
people used to love me for this comedy
and now they hate me and I know that
wasn't true but you know in that moment
it felt like that's your mindset what's
the like what's the point of doing this
if you're gonna turn on me
but again I think like when you're just
in a heightened
state of mind you don't really recognize
that there are a silent majority that
love who you are and then they haven't
stopped loving the content that you
created but also what was discouraging
was um you know jokes on Instagram was
getting like taken down or like every
time you would invest something and post
something like your channel will get
violations and all these things right
and then you're just like well [__] if
it's gonna harm the business potentially
then
what am I allowed to say and they're not
clear about it and that was kind of
scary because I think like I don't care
about a bunch of people like saying I
[__] hate you
um
but if it means now all of us like I
can't do this anymore because the
Channel's taken down and I can't you
know even afford like to keep this place
open like that was scary
and then without any any warning it can
happen
so I think that definitely
played a role in my mind because I never
had to edit
I was able to like freely speak and I do
still but it's so much different than
2016 Joe yeah yeah I don't know how do
you feel I mean you your channel got
absolutely butt wrecked murdered yeah
but uh no I I feel like almost uh well I
always feel fortunate I can't believe
I'm still even doing tubes like yeah
this long and you know me and Nick could
be doing our podcast for like [__]
almost five years or whatever four years
yeah
um and but but I remember I always
remember why like why I started it so
it's like you know with with our podcast
right our [__] they don't tell you show
we we started it because we were like
we're really in love with each other and
like we can't believe that
um it's not like like one of those
people it's like I have millions of
dollars I'm like I can't believe
everyone's not rich it's like it's like
I can't believe that everyone settles
was our thing I see yeah yeah and so
that's where it started from for us it
was like the spark that started for us
is like man the [__] that I wish I knew
growing up about like like oh man I wish
that people knew that like you don't
have to go for your first relationship
or your second relationship or your
third relationship where there are
things that are serious and they're
missing yeah yeah you can really wait it
out and you can actually just like get
that right person to come in and click
for you and actually our producer his
name's mark
and he actually just you know he's been
listening to us because he's been
[__] producing our show forever he
just met like the chick of his dreams
finally and he's like a divorcee and
like he just stopped doing the normal
thing which is like settle settle settle
right everyone who's suffering around
you says relationships are suffering
you're gonna suffer too that's what
relationships are about right and he
just like zoned out of that and just
focused on what he wanted instead and it
changed his life yeah and I live for
that because when you connect it's a
it's a completely different feeling bro
look at you yeah I mean that's you broke
up in my living room and look at you now
you're you're a married man yeah we can
finally talk about that I love that I
know right so sick congrats bro yeah
thanks you've had the craziest come
around ever I know and I mean when you
when you asked earlier like what was one
of the way like what gave you the
clarity and what gave you this energy
and the new turnaround and she's a big
part of it you know yeah just having her
um gave me a lot of stability women do
that like for guys that are like me that
are just constantly on the go and like
we're we're not thinking about the
future in the way that we don't women
have the capability bro no they don't
they think differently but I like the
different you know it's it's a good it's
a good kind of perspective that I don't
slow down and think about but she's go
go in her own way it's just a different
perspective and um when you can really
like I'm sure you know man like it's
just when you can work together on that
it it becomes it evolves into something
better yeah yeah yeah and it gets better
and better and that's what the weirdest
thing is when you have Joe's back and
you have trust yeah underlying all that
yeah it gets better and better and
better and better it does we just
celebrated our 10-year me and Nikki our
10-year anniversary together our six
year anniversary married because we
basically got married on the same day
that we got together 10 years 10 years
wow and like I wouldn't have it any
other way dang like I don't
really have a bad thing to say about
Nikki other than like just hilarious
nitpicky like funny things right like I
do with everybody including yeah
especially myself yeah but yeah no it's
it's very um it's it's honestly like a
beautiful
um thing when you have your person like
yeah because your person's like you're
bound like you're you're you're already
have like a you're bound to the earth
almost and and then you can kind of
start to reach out of that and I've seen
that with you because you were very
constricted before yeah like you were
very like protect Joe first and you were
in defense mode I completely respect
that and even as like we were doing live
streams and I was sending [__] into
your
your DMs after yeah they're like I was
like okay so just so you know like as we
leave the live stream the next place to
go is directly into Joe's Instagram DM
you are so funny when you you basically
alley-ooped a lot of
hookups for me that was that was awesome
dude I was just riding but that was a
great Rod that was a really great um
healing process yeah in general just
like
going back into the game feeling desired
dating like a lot of people they they
hate dating when after a long
relationship but I think you you help me
make it fun the type of people I was
dating to they were all very cool and
like
um
you know it's it was it was it was good
experiences didn't work out but they
were all like
I think you learned about yourself yeah
like I haven't seen you doing like it
was good because I've known you yeah and
then
I think everyone I
should try and Achieve that but I think
it's like if you if you're not in it you
don't know that that's the thing to do
exactly and I think because the majority
is like what you mentioned settling
because of you because like previous to
um you know breaking up in your living
room I think like we were both in that
situation for a long long time because I
think the worst thing that can actually
happen to a relationship is two people
who are kind in in in a way where like
you we had a lot of loyalty and duty to
each other
and we stuck around thinking that we had
to
because nothing was technically wrong
like there was no major like infidelity
issues or like massive lying and like
hurtful abuse and and whatever it was
just like to completely
different life goals and mentality
people that are like always friction
exactly because
it's like we're just yeah you're a risk
taker she wasn't as willing to take
those risks yeah she owns that she knows
that yeah she's says it many times and
I'm friends with both of you and I am
like yo you guys are wonderful people I
love both of you separately together we
can be
you know yeah it's just combustion all
the time philosophies right hey I I
don't believe in crypto I believe in
crypto boom right like it's like those
then I'm just using uh but if you're if
there's too many disagree disagreements
on just how you view the world and the
things that you want to do then it ends
up having too much friction I'm an
environmentalist I drive Hummers exactly
and that's how it was yeah and just this
wasn't a match it was like I was a vegan
and she's a carnivore or whatever and
it's like how the [__] are we gonna
decide on getting a jerky in my backyard
yeah but I think
what but you guys are still friends oh
100 but that's what I'm saying we still
work together exactly so like people
know that but behind the scenes like
there's there's still like there's no
hard feelings exactly so like it was a
beautiful breakup maybe the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen in my own
living room and it was yeah because at
the end that I think that's what made it
so horrible is the is the fact that like
there was really no legitimate reason to
if this was [__] 1910 it's like it's
like why yeah right well you guys would
live for 15 more years so you didn't die
but yeah die a smoke stack inhalation
yeah coming back from the coal mine and
like yeah yeah I know exactly but like
yeah it was it was not you know at this
point it's like okay this is convenience
then because we don't need to be
together but I remember during that time
there was no real
example
and so like if like let's say it wasn't
a catalyst like well well for like if 99
of the relationships around you are
dysfunctional and unloving right well I
don't want to say unloving but they're
going through hard times maybe in the
moment they're not being loving right
um then you just think that's normal
if your family members relatives best
friends whatever and they can't also be
a voice of guidance because so like
let's say they're they're working out
their own [__] right and if if it's only
one couple telling us saying like maybe
that's not a good idea you seem like
you're in the wrong yes or you seem like
you're delusional you seem like you're
delusional right you want a Disney movie
right it's like hey maybe it worked out
for you guys because you guys lucked out
yeah and not that I thought that way but
it it could just like just numbers wise
right you I'm getting all this
confirmation bias from people
that the majority of people around me
and I'm like maybe that's just what
you're supposed to do and from us coming
from both broken homes we don't have
that what to look at and that's why I
realize like having a partner that has
parents that are like loving and they're
still together is such a [__] big
deal
because like some parents are together
but they're not loving each other that's
my parents right and then that's hard to
see too but when you see like Hannah's
parents they [__] are they look
they're they're still friend like they
hang out we go out together
and it's like this is what produces
someone who believes in love and
marriage I love that yeah that gives you
hope it does and then so for Hannah
she's she's um never had a boyfriend
she's dated and whatever but I think
that's what she had high standards for
men which I feel like pretty dope that
she chose me
but she has three brothers too so that's
why yeah she has high standards of what
a good guy should be
her dad stuck around and then she also
after an argument like like like you
said earlier
um we're here for each other so an
argument happens but it's about to solve
and in the teamwork right yeah I have
your back right I want to understand and
it was the first time that I've like you
know early on in our relationship where
when we if we had a disagreement or
anything
um it was diffused immediately because I
realized that you know we're just trying
to figure out
what the other person is really trying
to say I wish more I if I could just
take a piece of like a sentence yeah and
just emblazing it and put it on every
[__] wall it would be that because it
really is so important to do that you
and me had to mix up one time yeah and
we had a dust up and it was like very
brief and but it was settled in like the
most loving way yeah because I mean at
the end of the day like I don't feel
threatened or hurt or or unheard by you
you felt the opposite you felt unheard
because it was like yeah yeah we went
from like hey Steve what's this about
yeah
total I un like you you hear me and
that's what you were saying to me like
like like okay yeah wow thanks for
listening to what I was saying right
because you came at me pretty hot but I
was like oh dude like I didn't know that
you were taking it and someone else was
pissing me off that made me yeah it was
it was not me it was not me but my
energy was up because they were like
were you yeah yeah you talked to me
right you didn't feel like you could
talk to this person and we found that
later but that was you know but it was a
beautiful moment for me and I and I like
I said it doesn't matter who you are but
in conflict resolution I wish more
people could just
root for their friend like like it
doesn't matter my friend's like yelling
at me I am rooting to understand where
my friend's coming from and like you
know and my friend is a rational person
that's why they're my friend that's why
I love my friend so I know that we're
gonna get there and we didn't it was
[__] squashed immediately but that's
the beauty of communication like that
yeah but it it doesn't help because most
people go like this you know why you
[__] up
let me tell you why you're a [__]
[__]
there's nothing better than our own
mistakes right like nothing better yeah
do you know why you [__] up
uh exactly dude no exactly well do you
know why you were being a [__]
[Laughter]
let me tell you 10 reasons why you're a
[__] idiot oh dude I remember doing I
used to do like you know years ago I was
doing shoots with this chick who I was
dating
and
um she was miserable on set like when
she's on set she was misery
and like it's one of those things where
it's like
why are you doing this first of all oh
it seemed like do you really want to be
an actor it's like why do you hate this
so much yeah do we do this for if this
if you hate this you hate waiting yeah
that's what this is yeah this is waiting
this is like they're setting up lights
and getting like the [__] you know
temperature of the room and they're
doing like room tell and then and then
this [__] is like
before we go do a shoot like after all
that like we did like a I don't know a
day and a half music video
and then after that
she has the audacity to be like wait you
you're going to shoot why aren't they
asking me and I was like because you're
a handful dude yeah I actually I didn't
know how to do this other than
just not even looking at her so I just
went around our our apartment at the
time and I was like oh you know I
I think I know why I have a theory about
this and I just kept on I kept on going
up to like different pieces of furniture
and like different things like
straightening things like I Gotta
Straighten a little bottle on the table
or something and I take a picture of the
wall and like straighten it and be like
I think it's because like yeah like when
we're on set hold on a second let me
just fix this real quick
you're such a [__] [__]
and I think it's a wake-up call right do
you think she understood I think after
that she did a little bit more I think
most people go
throughout life
impulsively saying things and acting and
not understanding how it affects other
people around them I completely agree
with you I think if you have parents who
are well off yeah you're more likely to
be an impatient person oh yeah yeah and
you're more likely to be like they're
wasting my time yeah but your time
doesn't mean [__] they didn't book you
for this job because you're such a
[__] [__] yeah the whole time right
oh my God yeah but that you know and
that's such a and we've all been that
[__] [__] yeah like at some point in
our lives whether it's on set or not
like we've all you but it's good to have
the perspective and not everyone does
and that's always the frustrating part
I don't know I think um if more people
were able to just chill out and think
before they say [__] it would we would
all be in a better place but
unfortunately like I don't know human
nature man bro if we thought before we
said [__] like JK news wouldn't exist
wait you're saying those jokes aren't
calculated yeah I did that was one of
the most absurd I've seen a lot of those
absurd things in my time but someone
saying that we had a script that was I
think that takes the taco that is that's
a lot of work I mean that's actually
kind of collateral it's not possible
it's super flattering it's so flattering
we shoot 20 episodes a day and back then
we used to shoot about 30 to 40. dude we
saw 28 when I was on the show we wrote
freaking wow get out of here I know you
guys you know it sucks a little bit
because you guys are like well we're in
the real war and I'm like I was I was in
the war with you guys but like yeah 28
episodes because no and the real [__]
was like we're doing [__] 38 Episodes
we're sleeping here and I'm like ah [__]
but they were like they were like 10
minute episodes so they weren't
absolutely thank you there's no off the
records there wasn't uh an eight minute
episode where everyone's looking at the
clock the whole [__] time
earlier mention
um I remember like the way we segued
into this was was
um the passion part of it right because
I
I think where you were getting at with
that is that like so do you have time
for passion right yeah because like JK
news is like a routine thing that we do
getting with the boys but was it ever my
true passion because back then I wanted
to uh create content like in the form of
narrative like shorts skits maybe even a
feature one day right
and I think what I realized and I had
this talk with Bart 2 because
for me I thought that my goal was to get
into acting and create this character
and and tell these stories right
and then I was like why didn't I fight
hard for it when I had that opportunity
to actually do the movies and all that
and then I could have spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars that I had on a
movie but I ended up doing other
businesses and things like that and I
realized I just love building businesses
with friends I hated Hollywood I hate
the smoothie I I wouldn't need to I
never want to sacrifice myself to do
certain things if if it just doesn't if
I don't if it's not worth it for me so
for example like
I mean you you actually made movies and
you actually were a part of that world
in the Indie space
but
you already seen a a bit of it and isn't
it exhausting because we're not like
that
when Trump won re-election I remember
being on the phone I'm not gonna say
where or when or anything
but I remember being on the phone and I
remember people
from a major Motion Picture company
being like my friends are gay are they
about to go into a camp and I was like
what in the [__] are these people are we
going to look they're gonna send gay
people to a concentration they're gonna
send my friends into a camp and I was
like what in the [__] are these people
even talking about I was like what are
these and I'm like I'm not even like
saying like oh like yeah yeah Trump's
the best I'm like no no like what are
you guys talking about like you're in
another world right so you're just in
like an elsewhere else world's um
universe
it's not real
it's so wild yeah that's what I mean
like so when I when that
that was one of my first examples of
that I also remember like during covet I
went and got a shotgun and like some of
the people that I knew in the in that
world were like very offended that I got
a gun but I was like I don't live like
in this like nice area you guys live
yeah so they could live in gated
communities with armed guards that do
the dirty work for them but then Van
Nuys yeah that's crazy I was like he was
on the border of Van Nuys but like it
was you know they only changed it
like they had like a city
um whatever
um provision to call it something other
than Van Nuys so property values would
maybe go up yeah yeah but like bro it
was Van eyes yeah and so but that but
these people are like
why would you even get a gun that's
insane you're gonna go shoot a school up
or whatever and so when when you start
to hear people talk like that you're
like
I don't think that we live in the same
world yeah I for sure we don't because I
like I look I believe in um like a
single mom needs a gun yeah because
there's somebody who's more powerful
than her exactly they don't even need to
go to the gym right they're just more
powerful than her because there'll be
guys like I could handle them with the
bat and I'm like yeah but what about my
grandma like you know like exactly yeah
and then so Hollywood was just full of
um just people I don't Vibe with you
know saying bro and then
I have support from my community you
know like like
um you know Asians that are that that
that's always been trying to get out
there break through and they did they
they made strides and they and I'm glad
that there were people that were willing
to do a lot of the things that you know
I just didn't want to because then
you know it takes a certain personality
to go in there and just be above all
that [__] and still go through the
auditions and then still work with
people that they might not necessarily
like but to me that's a that's a skill
in itself because you have to have a
strong personality and a lot of patience
because like us we don't we'll just get
into arguments straight up and then
we'll just tell people I think you know
what me you and especially David one of
our things we love doing is if someone's
a piece of [__] we can't
like in front of them yeah like and
letting everybody else know what a [__]
face they're being right and by the way
and I'm such a writer right I don't even
like the funk Bros because David doesn't
I don't like them hey I don't like them
right now you don't even know them
because of David but I'm a writer I'm a
[__] Rider forever yeah and then
that's how we are too like it's like oh
really David you yeah this [__]
producer was a dick to you all right
well next time I see that fool I'm gonna
[__] be so funny
everyone he's gonna leave there with his
tail tucked between his [__] legs
right and then I think
yeah and at the end of the day it wasn't
about achievements I think it was about
being able to continue a way of life and
freedom with my friends yeah and then so
you've proven that that's like literally
your life yeah and so it's I think if
passion it it isn't really just
um you know making the biggest hits or
doing this or whatever and I think I got
a lot of that out of my system in my
early years
and now it's just about
um like having a business idea
assembling a team getting excited about
it together and executing it well and as
boring as that sounds I feel like I had
so much creative stuff out of my system
that now I'm having a lot of fun doing
just like more traditional business I
don't know like no that totally makes
sense I mean you're literally proving
that you're showing up every day in
Hawaii making boba tea for people like
you're doing it yeah but you you clearly
like it a lot oh yeah I like it why
it's so different from the creative
field because like in entertainment
right there's a lot of emotions there's
a lot of Dreams it attracts a lot of
people who just can't function in the
more left brain world right and and me
too I'm that right and it's it's a it's
a lot of
um
it attracts also people who want to um
find meaning and purpose and self-esteem
and like
and like they want to get away from that
whereas like
something like a cleaning company or a
farm or like let's say even jumi right
um
things like that already exist and
people aren't going there to escape
and and find themselves or like be
somebody right like people don't be a
boba Barista because that's a life
passion they end up opening up their own
bubble shop if that's their life passion
but it's typically someone who wants a
fun cool job during college or like you
know no one's gonna be as passionate
about the product as I am in my team but
at the same time it's like
it's a good transition for them or like
if you have like a like a factory or
something right like people are going in
there to get the job done and then
they're done
I don't have to constantly
deal with people's egos in the same way
do you think people go to Tyson's
Chicken they're like I just love
chickens so much and then they go there
like ah [__]
oh [__] what I thought I was gonna be
I thought this was gonna be like a nice
thing with chickens I wonder what their
job interview is like so uh I love
chickens chickens I [__] love them
but no dude so so as you see so this is
interesting as a business owner you see
employees come in and they're it's a
transitory thing they're trying to get
through college or whatever
is there a way is there like I always
wonder this because corporate wise
corporate always does the slogan
[__] like the [__] rah-rah yeah
do you even bother or do you agree
people
um well it depends on the company
culture some people are really about
that like bro like
I don't know I think people just have to
ask my employees on how they like it
yeah but um but how do you approach it
of the the rah-rah corporate like hey
prepare daringly today guys hey good
morning prepare daringly when you're
making the tea today so our model is
prepared daring me but I think
you don't have to be so
um pretentious
yeah like I I choose a lot of chill
energies some people do have hype energy
but
um I like people who are very
comfortable in themselves and sometimes
there are people that are like very shy
but if I see those qualities about them
I'm like yeah you'll you'll gel well
with everybody else
and
they all work really well together
surprisingly about drama yeah
um
sidebar now
you're a married man yeah we can finally
talk about this yes I know right
as a married man do you have advice for
people out there who are looking to get
married
as a like hey you've been married I've
been married for a year
but before that [__] like
I've been in many relationships
long-term relationships several years
where I lived with my partner on many
occasions right
and on top of that just like a lot of
dating and hookups too so a lot of
[__] and sucking a lot of [__] and
sucking and licking and slurping and
whining and dining so if you look at it
traditionally
that means I probably divorced like five
times already because
just just back in the day like if you
actually moved in with the girl lived
with them and all that like it's kind of
the same thing
the only thing that's different is that
you're actually life planning with
someone you're married with
your family yeah and then and then you
see so you see life a little bit
differently but
even with girls that I was dating and
living with it felt pretty close to what
it is now
it's just that there wasn't any future
plans yeah
um the advice
would probably be
pay attention closely to how she treats
her family and her relationship with her
family if she has family love that yeah
that's so interesting why you say that
something that stuck with me
um
that my mom told me early on she was
like you could date all these girls but
you're marrying her family so like you
could date them but
is that your father that you want is
that you know her sister that you want
like like it's her family you're
marrying not her and then Saul's like
what does she mean by that and it just
kind of stuck with me and I would always
observe the family of the person I was
dating
um and I'm like am I gonna have friction
with this person or not but I would add
the the extra layers how shall does she
treat her parents that's really good
yeah and how does she treat her siblings
yeah nice
and I I think right right from the jump
you know Hannah's like
she's always involved in her brother's
lives they're all like friends they hang
out like we went hiking with their
brother like
um
you know her you just saw them in London
no uh yeah we were when we're in Wales
and yeah
um I've seen them interact you know and
I was like okay this is dope because
it's one thing to hear and know but like
to see it in real life and then be a
part of it and then knowing that that's
your family now too it's it's pretty
cool well the yeah gonna wrap it up now
it's time to wrap it up but I I do uh
genuinely hope for everyone listening
that you find a friend in life who is as
genuine and as great a friend as JoJo is
hey the same could be said about you bro
like you're genuinely
someone who wants the best for their
friends right like I don't really see
you as someone
and this is what I hate about a lot of
people is that like they don't sing
praises of their friends when they're
doing well they're in this internal
competition in battle and insecurity and
jealousy I don't get that from you like
you live your own life and you have your
own things that you like but you have
such a diverse group of friends because
I think you root for everybody's success
and I try to collect people like that
and it's a it's it's really a good trait
to have because there's so many people
out there that do the opposite like and
as soon as I notice that about people I
kick them out of my life yeah dude it no
it is look there's a like you said about
this town right it's transactional here
um but that's why you know I'm not a fan
of La really uh of the LA culture I
guess yeah um
but no it is it is a fascinating
Endeavor I guess to try to understand
but yeah I I um I just yeah like you
said I really root for people everybody
I hope everybody wins in life but I know
that sometimes to win you have to lose
and I'm one of those people who have
lost to learn to know how to win yeah
like and so to piggyback off of that
um where do you think the crypto Market
is going so right I mean crypto's here
to stay it's been here too long for it
to disappear yes sir
but I think it's gonna be you know like
the stock market but is it going to go
in the same like so for example when the
economy tanks right like well exactly
yeah like
the trend is typically what stocks first
and real estate
and then I'm wondering like if crypto
and stocks will work will be parallel
or will we see like would it would it be
an independent Market
or like will we see a different
I don't know you know like yeah yeah
well it's interesting too because so you
know we've been the crypto market for a
while
um do you feel like the crypto Market is
is something that
you want to be part of or is it
something that you feel like like as a
movement oh yeah yeah oh 100 I'm I'm
waist neck deep into it yeah and I'm
also very competitive and I'm so angry
that I lost 1.6 million
um 1.2 baby right that
uh a part of me is like no I'm gonna
lose five that's right next time you
know what I mean and I'm gonna lose 4.8
let's go baby
uh yeah I first lost 800 000 the next I
lost one point let's make that five
million hey but how much you put in
that's 10 million baby
right God imagine I know I think it's
going to be one of the things where
people are like you know you work so
hard you probably shouldn't just waste
it on crypto
well look my whole thing is like small
amount of money into a big amount of
money why are you risking a lot you
shouldn't you don't have to if you're
any good at it you should get sick
multiples right I'm up 80 right now on
the market in the last six months who
the [__] else is not really around you
look at shitty ass cardano and I'm
looking at you all Cardona holders 14 in
six months that's all you got let's just
tell the real truth everyone bought it
early thinking they were gonna pump it
together in unison and guess what
happened they fell prey too crypto
YouTube and guess what happens on crypto
YouTube you buy the thing way too late
it's so saturated everyone [__] knows
about it and you get wrecked you hold
the bag congrats on holding the bag but
it to me it was just like Ripple part
two like I know I'm gonna get ripped
apart for saying this but it's really
that's what it is that is what it is the
market yeah
the supply is insane the [__]
markup's insane you guys doing out there
there are gems out there gems in the
darkness gems in the woods and uh that's
my game anyway and I I look I got killed
with Luna of course yeah but guess what
still cashed out sixes and six figures
and guess what I'm still up 70 [__]
eight percent against all you [__]
well yeah well six months your principal
you gotta look at it this way it's like
what did you come into the game with
exactly like 10 G's exactly and you
turned 10 G's into what 300K in it right
or 28k 28 and 2 yeah 50 275 yeah that's
that's all I see though that's how I see
it as yeah I see it as this is someone
who put 25k that turned it into 300K
that turned it into almost uh 135 000
right and then you know you're still
free rolling that's that's just free
rolling right dude I haven't ever put
six figures in a crypto right never
gonna yeah I mean you gotta earn it
right so it's it's stages the the method
is stages right My Method anyway it's
like you you you do a small amount of
money into a big amount of money right
then you take profits on that big amount
of money and then you reinvest but you
just keep it small you gotta [__] do
this crazy [__] that people do like like
me like well I put in 300 000 but you're
a man and you were loving it yeah and I
uh and you came back from it and you
actually won hard yeah 1.6 mil
technically I did 1.6 mil out of 110. I
mean that's what I'm saying and because
yeah that's what the darkest day of OMG
it was 110 right well because when you
told me
um I think it was 2019 or 20 no no 20 I
got in 2017. when did you decide to sell
your OMG February of 2021 and 20 or 2020
I think it's 2019.
I want to say maybe it's 20 20.
I think it's 20 20. no when was the when
was the bull was it 2022-21 no the Bulls
started the well the bull really started
in 2019.
I mean the the the the
yeah that was uh God I can't remember
throwing ahead okay anyways you told me
you gave me a warning yeah you're like
hey I'm I'm out yeah and that's when I
was like
all right let's do it and then we went
to snx with snx and then we did AV yeah
well I didn't get the AV but I I barked
it yeah yeah yeah and then we rolled the
Luna so when I got out at that time it
was 110k yep
110 and K we kept trading trading
trading I built it up to sick moves 1.6
mil
and then and I was able to leave with
150. so technically I'm up 40K with a
hundred but
[__] it's about the gains right
it's about what we did with the small
amount of money yeah take a small amount
of money turn into a big amount of money
that's the point that you can even do
that is insane to people people live
their whole [__] lives doing a 401k
and they don't even get there and we did
it in like what 10 months yeah it's uh
and that's so I was having a talk with
Nikki recently just to close
it was it was our like I said 10 years
together six years married she's like
holy [__] you have turned like 20 grand
into a million dollars two times yeah
since we have since our wedding night
because I was getting people into
ethereum during my wedding
and I think there's still so much gains
to be had because it's 22 of the world
has crypto yeah 22 and in the Market's
not even close to what the stock market
is no way so like that's it baby 100
agreed yeah anyways means you always
have to flirt about crypto because yeah
we got it yeah
but hey thank you so much for listening
to overtime yep and don't forget to
check out overcooked which is the new
show over cooking baby